I am so happy to see y'all back together
for what the fifth time now yeah on
screen six maybe six times but I'm
wondering what male female co-star
combination of let's just say like 80s
90s 2000s sure
has been in more movies than we have
I'm trying to think off the top of my
head I can't think of it would be true
nice pull somebody got a full eight left
I got some sleepless you know well
speaking of Drew I just was talking to I
love her she's my sister I was just
talking to her today Drew and I were
talking about this and and we we
wondered I have the question is it the
one because for so long people thought
you were going to be a bachelor forever
people thought you thought I didn't
think you knew always that he would find
the one he has two yes much heart and
soul of like just truth and goodness to
not find the one is it the woman who who
changes you or is it you that change for
the woman a mom walked in the room and I
was clearly done you know I think you
were that way with Danny yes yeah
yeah so it's there you go then it's the
one it's the woman it's the woman oh
come on you've got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am I need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worse 19
years of my life we were only married
for five I'm counting the recovery did
you read the script first or did you say
it's Julia and I'm in first
it was together but the whole thing is
Kismet really because I get sent scripts
that get lost in the shuffle or that I
don't have time to read for weeks or you
know and this came and it was just I got
it sort of I was like oh I can sit down
and read this right now and we kind of
read it at the same time and we reached
out to each other at the same time and
said you know I'll do it if you do it
and then yeah to go from there to
actually it working out I mean it's
really kind of miraculous I thought I
could only do it if it's Julia and then
and I think we both felt the same way so
it was one of those things where we
thought well let's let's give it a go
and then everything sort of fell into
the place is kissing each other really
ridiculous it was I preferred kissing
you and you didn't have a beard
I have a beard now because you know I
shave in the morning and it grows by the
end he's so manly yeah this is such a
brute yeah the testosterone is shocking
yeah you should see my back
oh yeah all hair
you guys the guy's back pretty
impressive isn't it yeah did you get
that yeah cool looks like a that's gonna
be returning all day
it's gonna ride back up if I'm being
honest though I gotta call Matt my
producer Andy just said he's starting to
get the salt and peppers and he said one
morning I wish I just woke up and looked
like George Clooney like it was done
who's that you yeah yeah you look good
though you look bad if you think you're
the first man who ever said I wish I
could just wake up and look like George
Clooney
yeah it's getting it is that scary thing
though where I was watching the first
time we watched the film it was a sort
of a rough cut of the film and there's a
shot where I'm like walking through the
airport and it's just a big crowd of
people and I I literally see this this
old gray-haired guy and I was like who's
that and it's like oh that's me shut up
yeah I was like wait a minute I mean you
don't really see like the back of your
head and stuff I was pretty surprised
okay
in my mind 58 back there in my mind
nice
and I almost
happened that was good cut off three
years
I'm praying for an asteroid in my mind
the dance scene I had a different
version of how I saw you all grooving
how did that go well what did we do the
movie kind of sport a little bit for me
I see you guys I know you I know you can
dance I know I know you can dance I
don't like to brag you shouldn't really
I've Seen Her Dance too
I would think a little Tango wouldn't
you like a little
something oh yeah oh yeah what are you
really like on the Dance Floor the two
of you Unstoppable oh yes yeah waking up
the next day and you go why does my neck
hurt how does my back hurt and you yeah
we're gonna we're gonna get on all those
shows dancing dancing with the Schmucks
that's what we're gonna do
no I drink starting early in the morning
so right in that cup I knew it yeah
obviously comes with his own coffee here
let me have a quick sip of coffee
special coffee special but I
was that improvised
in was it in the script there was
nothing there was nothing that was
written down they actually had a a
choreographer who came by and the look
of horror in her face when she saw what
we could do we were like oh we've got
this yeah it was really funny she goes
so let me work on a couple of moves and
work we got it
and the same look on the other actor's
face when we when we started they were
just like
[Laughter]
I welcome you to my country and soon to
my home Mrs cotton this is mother you
can just call me Georgia oh best you
wish Georgia
yeah I'm good with Mr cotton
so the movie is definitely you know
themed around something your your
daughter wants to do that maybe you guys
don't think is the greatest idea when
you look back at your life and you think
about I was thinking about this during
the movie the things that my mama told
me not to do that I wanted to do and how
she would write every day
is there something you all think about
and say yeah they told me not to do it
and I did it anyway
mixing grain and grape my mother my
father told me never to do that they
were they couldn't be more right because
I boy it just
it starts the next day it's painful
right you guys know that you don't like
you have wine and then you
um I don't know what are things that
your what are things that your family
told you to do or not do well I think I
mean I don't know about saying don't do
that I I don't but I do know that when I
first moved to New York City
when I was 17 and I got there and there
were so many people it was all so fast
and my sister who I was living with was
so busy with school and her friends and
so I just going to the ATM I had to
really like muster up the courage to get
across all those Avenues to get my 20
Bill and then run back to the apartment
and um at one point I called her and
said you know
I don't think this place is for me I
think I'm going to come on back home and
she said I don't think that's a good
idea and at the time I just thought
wow I think she thought yeah she just
didn't watch it back in the house I got
one to go so I don't want you guys
boomeranging and thank goodness yeah
what a good thing I got a leverage for
myself good for me you got luggage I did
my mother was like happy birthday really
because my parents were like uh I think
my father was like you're not smart
enough to be an actor which of course
has never been a prerequisite that's an
interesting thing to say I think he knew
how hard it was to succeed and I think
he thought I would be disappointed so he
sort of said don't do it trying to spare
you he was trying to not even talk me
out of it which you know thankfully well
he didn't but you know that's what
parents would do in the you know he was
trying to do the right thing okay just
because we can never let this dream fade
away so just end
if we could get Tess and Danny back one
more time where are they what are they
doing
and that that is making me a master
theme
Robin Banks yeah
Bonnie and Clyde kind of stuff well
let's no that's no no that's too violent
oh see I I'm going violent she's going
like PG no clever no I'm going clever
we're sneaky ninja we want to do like a
you know an Ocean's 14 where we're just
all really old and everything we try to
do we throw our bags out yeah we're
retired we're and we're we're trying to
train for one last day
oh my God
let's go get
just getting out of the chair you throw
your back
[Music]